foreign  [Music]  ever  [ __ ]  oh  [Music]  holy [ __ ]  it worked  hey what's going on Gwen how are you  dressed hey I don't know what's going on  what's going on is it supposed to be  guarding the boss's daughter not  screwier oh I didn't sleep with her no  no  I mean yes  I slept with him many times but Timmy  that wasn't me that was the old me  I just got here like 20 seconds ago  really yeah and what happened to your  clothes no oh  would you believe me if I told you I  would stand here from the future  get out of your sweat yeah we're gonna  take care of this comedian no you're not  you're gonna give me the keys to your  car and some money for gas or are you  going to wake up in the hospital trust  me I know how these things play out oh  because you're from the future no  because of these  what the hell  [ __ ]  peaceful thoughts